many families also heading up to Mount
Charleston to enjoy the time off Madison
Kimbrough joins us from the snow with
the latest
spring break is in full swing here at
Mount Charleston and we spoke to those
who live in Vegas but also those who
traveled out of state to enjoy the snow
while many choose warmer climates to
vacation to for spring break those we
spoke to taking full advantage of the
fresh powder located just an hour away
from the city others flying from out of
town to enjoy the activities here's what
some visitors had to say about their
experience
spring break I know can be tough for
some moms because we're like oh what do
we do with them when they're not in
school this is a great place to go they
get all their energy out up and down the
hill so I'll probably bring them back
myself a couple times this week when my
husband's at work just so there's
something to do a lot of friendly people
super nights feel like I'm back in
winawaii except we're exchanging sand
for snow and as for parking it was very
limited as an HP blocked off the
entrance due to parking being at full
capacity a typical occurrence on the
weekends this location here at the upper
Lee Meadows Recreation Area is one of
the Prime spots to sled and traffic
coming up here wasn't bad at all
reporting at Mount Charleston Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now